[Music]
all right let's talk about your book
first off I love the title the strange
death of Europe I thought using the
adjective strange was particularly
interesting why did you choose the word
strange not slow more a series of other
things that you could have used the
first is it's a nod which not many
readers will get to a slightly known
history textbook the strange death of
liberal England which described the
decline of the Liberal Party in the
early part of the 20th century but less
that sort of isn't needed it was note
although there is a slight similarity
yes a really little thing is it's just
it is odd I mean it's it's a curious way
to go and I think if you'd have said to
anyone of one or two generations ago
that this would be what Europe's issues
would be in the 21st century that
basically it couldn't couldn't find any
way not to just allow the world to walk
in and join them that those generations
would have been surprised and so yes it
is it is strange it's and I but I try to
explain why and I and in order to
explain it I try to explain it from not
just from the you know the sort of
first-hand accounts and the statistics
and all that sort of thing but but the
deeper philosophical reasons why this is
happening
I think that's you know the lots of
books do bits of that well I want to
just say look this is the whole overall
picture this is this is what we're
actually living through and this is why
yeah so the subtitle is immigration
identity and Islam does that order have
any meaning to you in the way you phrase
those particularly I mean it centers on
the 2015 migration crisis when Angela
Merkel opened the doors of Europe and
couldnt really find a way to shut them
again but they'd already been open for a
long time as I explained though I mean
it's these these are the three massive
things that that are preoccupying I
think not just Europe but Europeans
the immigration crisis where the
public's of Europe just wanted to stop
all across the content all the polls all
show the same thing the public wanted to
slow down or stop so that's the
immigration bit of it the identity bit
of it is the very very painful thing
which you know people aren't very good
at talking about maybe I'm not very good
at talking about it but I think it's
just there underlying everything what is
this thing what is it to be a European
who who can be European can anyone be
and is Europe home for the peoples
who've been in Europe or is it home for
anyone in the world who wants to move in
and call it home he's a very very big
question yeah these are bad and then the
third one of that is the Islam bit which
I mentioned because it's obviously the
sharpest bit of this ah you can have
somebody move in I know you can have a
Nigerian Christian move into a bit of
the South of England and they will have
issues they bring as everyone does they
will have their own ideas as everyone
does their own culture they've walked in
from and everyone does but it would be
the person of another background for
another community in another faith who
would be coming in with the issues that
are really starting to nor it Europe we
we find this very hard to talk about and
it's getting easier very very slowly but
you know our big worry is we've not been
great on the integration all of our
leaders say this all the European
politicians admit this now but the bit
that is is worrying us is Islam bit
because I think there's now a general
awareness that maybe this is the bit we
can't digest or we're finding it
unusually difficult to digest and
incorporate I don't say it's impossible
by the way I just think for all sorts of
reasons it's proving very hard in May in
the years ahead proved far worse so I
know that you often make the distinction
like most educated people you make the
distinction between Islam as a set of
ideas
as any religion is simply a set of ideas
versus Muslim as as people in this case
do you think that there is something
unique I mean this is always what
triggers my friends on the left
if you say that there is something
unique about the set of ideas of Islam
that is different than the set of ideas
if we just take the big three
monotheistic ones that is different than
the set of ideas of Judaism Christianity
or at least how their practice
I think is the more operative part
because you can look through all the
books and there's plenty of bad stuff in
the old testing do you at the end of
this do you believe that it's just
incompatible that this set of ideas is
incompatible with the set of ideas that
the West is trying to preserve I think I
think unreformed Islam presents a very
significant values challenge and it's
probably not reconcilable if if we have
as it were the Islam of most Muslim
countries it's it's very hard to see how
that's doable I think all of this is
very painful isn't it because first of
all we live in any case in an age of
relativism already where four perfectly
good reasons sometimes you know we sort
of pretend it's all sort of the same you
know I might be a Muslim you know you
might be a Christian she does yoga and
it all comes out in the wash right it's
the same and I just think that's to
begin with that's obviously not true I
mean it's very strange to to want to
concentrate on everything other than the
premises and origins of a belief
structure mhm
and as I've often said stop me if I've
said this to you before but I mean you
know there are all sorts of problems in
the Christian religion and in Christian
history but as I've often said you know
what just carry out the thought
experiment that instead of getting up at
Sermon on the Mount and saying you know
love thy neighbor and you know and
forgive people endlessly Jesus have said
if your brother offends you chop his
head off would Christianity's history
have been more bloody or less bloody I
think we all agree it's gonna be more
right well I'm buying the Jew behind the
tree yeah yeah if Jesus didn't say that
but if Jesus had got into the whole like
fine you know the Jew behind the tree
and slaughter him yeah
at whatever the context right then there
would be even more a Christian
anti-semitism and then there has been
historically so I just think these
things matter and I all this is very
very painful for a reason that I go into
in some depth in the book which is that
in recent years we and countries like
Britain I think in America have had the
luxury of sort of describing ourselves
in terms that are among other things
have been universal but what we have
should also be universal now this is a
very big this is always a debate within
liberalism of course is liberalism
something we have or something we as it
were expound and and and expand and in
recent years I think that a certain
moroseness has landed across Europe
among other things because of a growing
awareness maybe what we have is very
unusual and that we have become
disassociated from the roots in which
what we enjoy grew and this this is a
problem there's a German legal theorists
I quote in the book who puts this is you
know one of the central conundrums for
Europe is it possible is it possible
that the thing we're enjoying and living
through can survive without the
connection to its roots and I believe
that the roots of the West and of Europe
in particular fairly clear and it's a
combination of things it's the
inheritance from ancient Greece and
ancient Rome it's obviously the
inheritance of the Christian
civilization that washes through that
throughout the continent and then the
refining fire of the Enlightenment sand
skepticism and all these things and of
course we go and endlessly about the
other things that have added to it but
broadly speaking that is what made
Europe Europe and what made a European a
European they breathe this this air but
but but the sort of the last man at the
end of that which I fear modern
Europeans are is is in this strange
position of finding it hard to even
identify
where he and she has come from let alone
being able to return to those roots and
nurture them because we all have I have
I'm sure you have a conflicted set of
views about this you know is it
necessary for other people to believe
those of us who had who have sometimes
been tempted to hope that for instance
skepticism is enough yeah
constantly depressed by the discovery
that for instance somebody may be a free
thinker about God and that's it
rethinking point of view yeah from then
on it's tribe all the way and you know
we're all we're all living through this
but it's for Europe I think that the
combination of the historically
unprecedented moving to people in for
continent at the same time that this
sort of breakdown of what we are
ourselves is going on is a is their
fatal fatal thing so there's a lot there
that I want to hit but I what you said
right at the beginning which is that if
Islam if unreformed or not allowed to
reform so I think that's particularly
interesting for the space that you and I
sort of exist in because I have many
allies who are reformers I'm not just I
allies that are X Muslim I have allies
that are Muslim and keep many many
people that I've interviewed that you
know but they're treated horribly
horribly and there and every time
they're allowed to get a platform or
talks it's actually by the evil
conservatives yes people right yeah or
all the things that people who don't
like me you'll say about me or show
about you or any of that stuff is that
makes the job a good Julian time well I
say in the book towards the end when I
try to rouse myself to some
prognostications about all this that
this is the worst possible sign not just
that the people that we might talk about
in these terms are so few and that
between us you and I might have them in
our phone books not just that but who
are the ones that are most Thunder under
pressure and under risk they really are
the there they go guys to say that this
is a tragedy for Islam is obvious
but it's always been my view that we
should try to avoid making ourselves a
casualty of Islam's civil internal
strife and I think we haven't done that
I think we've spent recent decades
almost deliberately running towards a
fight that didn't need to involve us
mm-hmm so that the tragedy of Islam
becomes a tragedy of the West as well I
hope this could be avoided but I think
it can't and I think that as I say the
worst possible sign for the future is
that it's you know hammered apple salad
in Germany who lives under protection
let's imagine nowise who comes in for
all the grief in the UK it's like Yom
Hirsi Ali who followed the Dutch
integration I deal more than anyone yeah
who ends up having to leave Holland yeah
these are very very bad signs you know
you can still live openly as they no
Hamas military commander in London nice
fine yeah you'll be celebrated in some
ways right I mean this is a huge one all
right so let's let's knock out each one
of these words we've sort of hit that I
think a bit of each one already on the
immigration front when you said that
Merkel or just open the doors I see a
lot of different stuff written about her
that she either intentionally you know
you get sort of the conspiracy people
that she wanted to destroy Europe or she
hates her own country and all this stuff
I try not to impugn everyone's motives
but when this happened in 2015 and there
was this combination of refugees and
immigrants and migrants and nobody could
figure out what was happening and we saw
videos of people just thousands of
people just running across borders and
all this stuff and an odd amount of them
that seemed to be men in their 20s and
not women and children and all that
which implies that they're often
migrants looking for work well even a
user [ __ ] the Frontex figure seven
the majority of the people became in
2015 have no right to be in Europe which
is which is fascinating and somehow even
if you say that you'll be labeled
whatever but what do you think her
intention was in 2015 well I this is why
I try to go back to the beginning not
just with history but also with the
philosophy on this
I don't impute you know terrible motives
to her I think that she was blackmailed
by history was facing a truly terrible
humanitarian crisis which was
undoubtedly
on and I stare this in the face and I
travel around and speak to many many
migrants from all over the world have
been to many of the countries they've
fled from but I also go to speak some in
the countries that they arrive into and
speak to in the camps and certainly I've
met and listened to more migrants and I
think any of my critics but you know
it's it's it's that it's easy to our to
exaggerate the ease of a situation that
she faced or the ease of the solution to
it and and I think that shouldn't be
done it was a genuine crisis it remains
a genuine crisis and the biggest
imaginable moral question mm-hmm so we
also know that at the moment that she
made the decision in 2015 to basically
suspend all border controls I suggested
in my book but since it my book come out
has come out it's already now being
confirmed by somebody was with her at
the time that what happened in
particular was that somebody said to
Merkel we cannot have German border
guards repelling migrants and the photos
go around the world right so this is
just condemned because of history it's
what yes is what one French philosopher
calls the second career of Adolf Hitler
mm-hmm
it's an ugly way of looking at it but
it's it's it's not entirely impossible
mm-hmm this is this is just this is
another go around this terrible terrible
history and past but you know it's not
conspiracy I show in the book how much
it's more what we call in England
cock-up I've always tended towards a
cock-up view of history because if you
see politics up close as I have done
quite a bit throughout my life you know
that it's not really people pursuing
Grand sort of schemes really it's people
who haven't done the job before because
you can't and there is no qualification
that gets you in position beforehand and
trying to deal with not long-term things
but tomorrow morning's headlines and you
know media action the next day and they
maybe they drown below the surface of
this babble yes that's how politics
happens these days right which is not
the way that both sides
about politics they wanted they want to
make it seem like the other side has
constantly this grand plan and
everything's going according to the hand
or as I say in the book the every single
thing we thought would happen didn't
happen and nothing that has happened was
expected I go back into the 50s you know
the guest workers who were the first
people who came in after the war a first
migrant waves into Europe from Turkey
and elsewhere Merkel herself said in
2010 we expected them to go home that's
incredible markup yeah but then we
expected to go home then it didn't of
course they wanted having tasted first
world you know
economics and among other things they
wanted to bring their families and of
course and if you have your families you
have enter the schooling system and
you'll need health care and then you'll
need it as an element especially if the
state's giving you a lot yeah this thing
and and that's why we are we are we're
where we are we're we're you know the
2011 census identified people who call
themselves white British on the census
as a minority in London minority in 23
out of the 33 London boroughs it's why
all the demographic projections from
across the continent show Europeans I
think not to overstated losing the place
they had to call home or at least
becoming a minority in it and this you
know there are some people who talk
about that and in the sort of language
of haha and the Empire Strikes Back now
you're getting a taste of it you went
round the world and now the world's come
to you and among other things I warned
those people just be careful of that
language the language of punishment
because if the language of that is as it
were the punishment for colonialism then
down the road you'll create a movement
it'll say well we managed to end
colonialism yeah and then they'll come
for you too no matter no matter what you
do so with that being said so the
identity part then is obviously
inextricably linked to this when you see
the this sort of what seems to be the
rising white identitarian movement or
European identity
movement or whatever what do you what do
you make of it do you view it purely as
the natural reaction to this is there
anything legitimate out of that it are
there parts that are not racist or is it
truly based in racism I'm very very
worried about this at the moment I have
to say very very worried if you have
people saying I'm proud of the color of
my skin because it's a skin color of
course there will be some people who'll
do the opposite I am somebody said to me
the other day evidence in question are
you proud of being white and I said no
of course not why would I be proud of a
pigmentation but I didn't turn around
and said no but I'm if you ask me if I'm
proud of my culture I'd say of course
but it's something else than that I am
it's not really about pride in the
culture III some years ago I wrote a
piece about this for book the Prime
Minister Gordon Brown was editing on
Britishness and I said I I don't think
of these things in terms of patriotism I
think of it in terms of gratitude I feel
gratitude before I've been lucky enough
to be all into I'd love it if other
people who wanted to be part of it
became a part of it and I think they can
and I think it shouldn't be and can't be
racially exclusionary I mean it's
madness but it's a madness it seems to
me that some people will be falling into
by being pushed and by being ignorant
and other things but you know I come
back to this thing there will be some
people who will and I've found this a
lot in conversations across the
continent in the last year or two there
will be people who will grab a bit of
the identity thing for themselves for
tactical reasons we will get to this
goal and we'll use a dishonest tactic
just like you're using it yeah and there
will be other people who will say no
it's not just a tactic is what it's what
I feel it's what I believe I just
strongly urge people not to go down that
route strongly urge them not to go down
the route of identifying by an accident
of skin pigmentation
but to say if you if you want to talk in
terms of values and in terms of
civilization and of culture you cannot
make it exclusionary like that but the
point about this is it's that that can't
only be that it's the as it were white
young guy who's told that right you've
also got to tell it to the angry young
black demagogue who's telling people of
their own skin color to isolate and
congregate around around race it's good
everyone's got to you know to make the
deal as it were on this yeah but I just
AM filled with with you know concern
about this and that probably has a
little something to do with the word
strange because it seems to me that it's
possible that the ship has already
sailed on this perhaps more in Europe
than in America because you guys had an
integration problem already which is
finally being acknowledged now but then
you also have this new set of people so
even if everything was fantastic yeah
with all the people that were there and
all the integration before 2015 what he
even do with just the new set of
problems let me give an example by the
way the in Scotland there's it's a small
amount now but a Catholic Protestant
mainly centered around football
supporting Celtic Rangers where they go
by religious affiliation ok still yes
still yeah that's because of a movement
of Catholics from Ireland into Scotland
a long time ago yeah let me give you
another example I had a very dear friend
who died recently who was a brilliant
very very brave man called Shona
Callaghan who was a double agent within
the IRA my other trouble than he he got
up to the top of the IRA command and he
was informing all the time to the Irish
state and saved many many lives he was
an extraordinary story man I wrote an
obituary for him and others of his
friends did one of the most negative in
fact one of the only negative pieces of
our Shore
was in the Boston Globe who referred to
him as a as a as a grass as somebody who
after you've come out and written his
memoirs came to hawk them around America
not not just selling a Morgan we're
talking about mm-hmm why would that
appear in the Boston Globe
only because a very long time ago a
large number of people from Ireland
arrived in this country and settled in
Boston and held on to their Irish
identity and some of them held on to a
belief that the IRA a murderous
murderous sectarian gang were as it were
their people so all these centuries
later the attitude in the Boston Globe
when a man who risked his life just and
save many many other people's lives dies
these to attack him basically as a grass
and a snitch okay
that's the movement of Catholic Irish
people into America
who on earth thinks that when you bring
the entire developing world into Europe
including very very large numbers of
young men from the Muslim world but this
is going to be sorted out by next
February yeah you know or you know
roughly this time next year so does this
show you know I use the phrase lazy
thinking all right but maybe that's not
the right way it shows an inability to
think you know what you said about
Merkel in 2010 it's like well we thought
they were going to leave that's not lazy
thinking that's man did you even think I
mean you know it's pretty good in
Germany you know if you let people in is
there ever been a self-imposed a group
of people that left a western country to
go back to it up to sighs thank you very
uncommon yeah of course once people once
people you know realize that the
economics works better
Europe does in in sub-saharan Africa of
course of course they come but we I mean
we're we're just so torn about this and
I I think we have to rouse ourselves to
more than moroseness we're torn about it
it seems to me because we're not sure
why oh yeah I'm pretty
why but as countess we're not entirely
sure why it should be our right to keep
anyone out I'm not here this obviously
America now America has a definition of
course it's America it is it's
legitimate to say America is a nation of
immigrants yeah it's not legitimate to
say that about Britain it just isn't
hasn't been till the late 20th century a
nation of immigrants me a very very
static population even the Norman
Conquest the thousand years ago shift in
the population by about 5% in the UK so
you know I understand that in America
the whole thing to do with immigration
is a bit harder people feel they're
talking not about them but about you or
me
and in Europe that that is a bit of the
case now there are people who talking
those terms but there's also there's
also just this additional thing of by
what right
by what right would I be allowed to say
anyone can't come now I think there are
all sorts of ways you argue it I mean I
the law should matter right the law
should matter the difference between
legal and illegal is everything yeah
look I'm not a Canadian why is that
because we have a border right and that
means that a Canadian has to obey the
laws of Canada yeah and I have to obey
the laws of the United States people
think that even and of itself but that
somehow controversially by the way what
a beautiful thing it has been watching
Justin Trudeau have to face it's so easy
for politicians in Europe we've seen a
lot you've seen it here in America
Canadians have seen it it's so easy to
grandstand on this let them in open the
doors because when the effects happen
hopefully you'll be out of power and
you'll be retired somewhere in a nice
area with lots of people like you which
was your dirty little secret all along
he'll move to New Zealand
isn't that where they're all moving New
Zealand that's me but but the Trudeau's
on he briefs were berated and morally
grandstanding and then of course when
this movement of people from America
across the Canadian border they start to
get worried Bill Gates
by the way at the beginning the migrant
crisis said that America should take in
the same proportion of migrant
that year was Germany did Germany took
in an extra 2% of its population in one
year alone and Bill Gates and we should
taking the same numbers in in Germany in
its Germany did in Britain America well
interesting enough only a couple of
months ago Bill Gates did a reverse
ferret on that actually no he said he
certainly said remarks that if Germany
continues like this it's it's going to
destroy it well imagine if Bill Gates
instead of being the world's richest man
had been in charge of anything mm-hmm
then you'd have gone through what
Germany is going through and it would
have vastly outlasted him as this will
outlast Merkel and all of us so the
issue it seems to me there's two things
that I can point out one is demanding
that our political leaders in particular
think through things beyond the two-year
electoral cycle or the four-year
electoral cycle or more importantly just
tomorrow at the morning's headlines
right you might have a bad morning's
news it's a lot better than [ __ ] up
your country it's a lot better it really
is and the second thing about this is we
have to develop the ability to have an
adult discussion about these things that
recognizes it's not between you know
you're for the migrants I'm against them
or you know your Churchill I'm Hitler
your Chamberlain your Hitler just to
have the discussion on recognizing these
are different opinions about our future
and and that you know I'd say toward the
end of the book that we have the tools
for doing this Aristotle showed us a
long time ago this is just a competition
between virtues angler Merkel very
understandably felt the human virtue of
mercy to be merciful towards people who
are trying to come and I say yes but
there is another virtue competing with
that which is a virtue of justice not
just justice for the people of the world
wanting to come and have a better life
but justice for the peoples of Europe if
you have the discussion on those terms
between competing virtues not being good
and evil right and wrong Churchill
Hitler me good you Nazi then you might
being able to get somewhere in this
discussion but it's as if we've sort of
wounded ourselves before even starting
at the start line yeah so as two people
that try to engage in that I think
that's what we consistently try to do
and I see you debating all sorts of
people from every walk alike yeah i have
a promiscuous debating yeah you debated
basically everybody everyone yeah i some
people have like you know now in prison
not because i had debated them so much
they were prosecute mean you know i've
debated lots of people who I'm sure
you've sent a couple of people to mental
institutions after they've had to deal
if you are wit read it's not that I mean
I definitely if if somebody is is out in
the general public and has a platform
and and they wanted to bait I always
have the view yes yeah that's not say
all debate anyone by the way sometimes
people get oh yeah oh you wouldn't
debate me you've got two Twitter
followers yeah and you're nuts yeah
you're a blue fox on Twitter yeah you're
like Xena Warrior Princess
nah no nothing every kill that woman
really wants to debate alright I think I
think we got a nice holistic piece of
this here so I want to just shift
altogether to end this on a something
somewhat on the uplifting as someone
that that does all this that you speak
about this stuff you deeply care about
this stuff I you know I worry about this
stuff constantly people I was be staring
off into nothing in the middle of the
day and I'm literally worried about the
fate of the Western world you know I I
wish I was playing video games again as
much as I used to but yeah you know me
that much well I lost you on the video
game thing yeah but what do you do for
fun what do you do to just forget all
this stuff and just enjoy yourself and
be human oh gosh I
well I know you don't like this type of
question because this is well I'm rather
careful about as it were private matters
I am very happily in a relationship as
many years I love my family I've got
wonderful friends I see them a lot I to
relax I'm I read I read all the time
not just it's enjoyable but because it's
just just endlessly learning and
thinking and so it's just so stimulating
sometimes when you have that thing of
what I described is catching up with a
truth you'd always known was there
mm-hmm
the thrill of recognition that you get
from reading that I think is harder to
find in video games or get television
all right so you know I do a lot of
reading as I'll shift this a little then
so what would you say more importantly
than that to the to the person that's
watching this the type of email that I
get all the time the person that is just
a regular person you know working a
regular job that sees these problems
that here's you that is not a bigot and
it's not a racist but is genuinely
afraid of doing what you do everyday
which is say what you think that they're
genuinely afraid of just putting their
thoughts out there be it on social media
or be it it's getting to the point where
they're afraid to talk to their own
spouses about what what could you say to
somebody to give them a little bit of a
boost oh I tell you what the waters not
as cold as people say it really isn't I
mean it's it's hard this one isn't it
because if you there has been a lot of
focus on the negatives certainly some of
the things we're talking about today in
recent years and there's a sort of
growing feeling unless you want to
revisit recent interviewees a Google guy
is a demonstration the more that stuff
happens the more that people keep down
and it's very hard to I mean you can't
be brave for other people you can't tell
other people you know speak up but I
think we can encourage each other to I
mean um you know sometimes people
approach me in a sort of
and so again no it's great I'm right you
know I I have cocktails my friends I go
to concerts I read things I want I enjoy
the music I love and and I travel where
I like I go all over the world and we're
not gonna need any extra security
tonight are we i hey we're going to
Beverly Hills I think we'll probably
done Windsor you pick a fight with any
clatter but no I am I mean it's either
there's a sort of exaggerated yeah well
that's it that's why I'm asking you this
question because I do think it's partly
in people's mind you starts being and
then you realize yeah I know you know
somebody said some bad stuff about me
but I feel here
yeah exactly so people sound quite a lot
of the time young journalists and thanks
Amy I'd really like to write this but no
I don't dare and all this sort of thing
and you know I'll get this yeah look
just just to see and just write it and I
mean no one ever rewarded somebody for a
career in journalism the way they said
nothing over there are some writers at
New York Times you could you could say
but you know you just just dissed dude
and if if it doesn't I'm very lucky in
that I've spent my career saying what I
think and being able to earn a living
precariously but successfully and I feel
like I can write for almost any of the
newspapers I want to write for and
almost all of them will have me and I
love writing for the range of them like
I've very lucky to do this but it's not
like it's not that's rare I mean I mean
it's it's still legal to say what you
think and and I saw I just hate it when
people say like really my you for saying
what you're thinking what the hell do
you do and but it's only it's only that
we all we all get used to the idea and
just just sort of just one thing which
is just all so I tend about you but I
find myself more and more tolerant of
people's opinions just more and more
tolerant of it I mean I see I see people
driving themselves mad yeah and I just
sort of think I mean there are some
things I have somebody you know they do
I discovered they were into you know
Kitty fiddling or something and I'd have
something to say to them but pretty much
you know on politics and all sorts of
things I find myself like oh that's
interesting why do you think that
and and you know it's fascinating and
who would want to keep all that down and
you know as long as we agree on the
parameters as long as we agree that you
know we don't shoot and stab each other
which is obviously up for negotiation it
seems at the moment but as long as we
don't do that venom hey what's the
problem
just just speak don't expect somebody
else to do it for you I don't don't
don't siphon it off like some wing of
government like the free speech Center
it's for you to do thrust to do so
everyone that's a end an interview
Douglas Mari is on the Twitter he is I
have just been informed via the
teleprompter you're a thousand followers
away from a hundred thousand is that
right no you're monitoring this
constantly yeah and I must have these
which I think we can get you there
should I do something like if I get a
hundred thousand followers I'll do
something what would you do I don't know
him risa discusses well this guy's it
over drinks all right for more on Doug
let's follow him on the Twitter he
doesn't care that much but I want the
man to get 200,000 its Douglass came Ari
thanks
you